両者見合って　両者見合って
はっけよーい
のこったのこったのこったのこったのこったのこった
楽しくない！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
今見てもらった通り　トントン相撲やってありますでしょうか
昔は結構やったことあったんですけどもその
台とかね土俵とか作って
紙を折って作った人形でこうやって
トントントントンやって
最後まで倒れずに生き残ってた人が勝ちっていうね
こうトントン遊ぶトントン相撲っていうゲームがあるんですけども
クソつまんねーよ！
あぁん？正直言うけど何も楽しみが分からんわ
いやわかんないよ、子供の時は楽しかったのかもしんないよひょっとしたら。
でもこの24歳になった今実際にやってみるとクソつまらんわ
ビックリしたよ！
大人がやるならねもっとこう
ダイナミックに
もっとエキセントリック
エキゾチックな遊びにしたいと思ったので今回こちらを準備しました
おいしょっと
今回はコチラ
見てもらったらわかると思うんですけど
ミシンでございます
ひとまず開けます
うーーー
はいというわけで今回はコチラ
えーーっとなんかぁ
これ買った経緯を説明しましょう
あの僕やりたかったことがあって
トントン相撲が物足りないから
もう人間だと再現できることのできないくらいの
トントンスピードでトントン相撲やりたいと思ったので
もしそれを実現しようと思った時何が必要かと言ったら
人間より速いこのトントン動きが必要だと思いまして
そこでミシンを準備しようと思って僕､アピタに行ったんですよ
で、そのアピタでミシンおじさんみたいな人がいまして
たまたまその時アピタに行ったらミシン販売コーナー
ミシン買うなら今やでみたいなおじさんのコーナーがあって
で、そこで僕ミシンの速度ねトントン、ミシンでここでトントンするんですけど
トントンの速さが一番速いミシンどれかなとみてたら
おじさんに捕まっちゃって
で、僕のリクエスト言ったわけですよ
なんとか僕の言ってることを理解してもらって
勧められたのがこちらのミシンでございます
これね
めっちゃ高いからね
動画の為だから仕方なく買ったけど
普通にミシンとして使うには高すぎると思います
JUKIのHZL-V2000てやつです
値段調べよ
値段が全然出てこないなぁ
これひょっとしてヤバいの買ったんじゃねぇかな
価格は基本的にお問い合わせになってるぞ
俺さ
最高のトントン相撲がしたいわけよ
（ ＾ω＾）おっ　（ ＾ω＾）おっ
うわああああやっべ
まじか！
やばい
えーっと、ネットで調べたんですけども
こちらの HZL-V2000
えーーー
税込み価格170,640円でございます
( ^)o(^ )
ﾅﾝﾃｺｯﾀ...ﾀｶｲ...ﾀｶｲ...
でもねおじちゃんすごいまけてくれたんですよたしか
”お兄さんせっかくミシン買ってくれるんだからなんか安くして色んなの付けてあげるよ”って
下に敷く用の机とか
ボビンだよボビンボビンどこ行ったっけ
ボビンも付けてくれたんだよたしか
ボビンをここに入れてボビンオロゴン
はいというわけで史上最強レベル
業者が使うような速度でバンバントントン相撲できると思うので
人間対最高速度のミシンでトントン相撲バトルしていきたいと思います
まずは実際にこの最強のミシンの速度を調べてみましょう
なーにアピタのミシンおじさんが言うからにはこれが最強に速いと言ってたので
その実力はもう信じていいと思いますよ俺は。
全くわかんないんだけど、電源はこうか
これだな
( ﾟДﾟ)え？
ビックリした
これを足で押せば付くんですけど手で押しても動きます
なんで？
お店でおじいちゃんがやった時は
もっとﾊﾞﾝﾊﾞﾝﾊﾞﾝｱﾊﾞｱｱﾝってなってたよ
おぉ来た来た
これだこれだ
MAX速度
うわああああ！！
ひとまず危ないので針だけ抜いちゃいましょう
針だけ抜けました
よーーしOK OK バッチリ
はいというわけで
早速なんとかしてフィールドにコイツをセットして
戦わせてみようと思います
*ﾚﾛﾚﾛﾚﾛﾚﾛ*
最高速だぜアイツ
見合って見合って～
はっけよーい
のこった！
( ^)o(^ )
はっけよーい
のこった！
もしもし？母ちゃん、明日ミシン送っときますわ